ah yes this is the greatest video I've
seen of all time this is so funny and
sad at the same time but God damn this
is how is this a real way to say that he
really did this the thing about the red
hat that drove me to a point of
exhaustion which was misdiagnosed by a
I'm not gonna say what race what people
uh doctor
and what hospital and what media went to
we know I can't say that
it was a Jewish doctor
dude
couldn't help himself dude digging so
deep guys in China dude can't like how
did he do it honestly take away the fact
that it's anti-semitic I get it he
shouldn't be doing this the guy's
unhinged he's got mental problems you
know it's sadder than it is evil it's
not evil I don't believe he's a bad guy
but I feel like he's got to stop no
one's stopping him we got to stop giving
him Outlets stop recording them dude
let's I don't know it's like it's just
it's not a good idea the guy's unhinged
and he's mentally unstable but my main
quest take away all that how did he do
it
so funny
he did like if this was in a movie I'd
go oh guys should be best actor along
with Javier Bardem in lilac crocodile
and Austin Butler in the Elvis movie
dude
the guy did it the timing of it if you
got it down to the millisecond the
millisecond a fraction of a millisecond
this guy just I mean do you understand
this is funnier than anything Ed Helms
ever did
the thing about the red hat that drove
me to a point of exhaustion which was
misdiagnosed bumbling by hey I'm not
gonna say what race what people uh
doctor
and what hospital
we know I can't say that
it was a Jewish dog
dude he just nailed it this [ __ ] makes
me think that maybe he's actually I mean
I know he's not trolling because you can
see behind his eyes he's got some real
[ __ ] issues but my god dude
he's so funny
and it's sad take away all that you got
to take away all that because if you
actually live in the world and
understand what's happening it's sad if
you think about all that he [ __ ] iced
that [ __ ] comedically
it was a Jewish doctor I mean just
like we knew already you know
well ready to know where it was going
and that from jump
so uh Connie is [ __ ] hilarious dude I
feel real you know he's funny like
Trump's funny he's F you know what I
mean it's
just iced it yes got me got me good oh
it just got me just iced it
um
honestly uh Kanye should just be like
that was my Halloween costume it's just
an anti-semite Adidas let me have that
deal back
[Music]
[Music]